steve carell says his wife nancy is his
protector that's home and family for me
ET sat down with the actor ahead of the
premiere of his new film
welcome to Marwin where he dished on his
and his wife's special bond what is it
for you that brings you out of the dark
place what's your mechanism my wife and
kids for sure that's that's yeah that's
my when people talk about their happy
places that's the home and family for me
it's the only way mark skinnygirls
the idea of women is a really really
important component of the film too
because the real mark hogan camp is
surrounded by women in his real life and
and truly trusts and loves women more
than anything they're his protectors
they're the person who found him left
for dead the people in nursing back to
health people who continue to help him
out and one he's protected by these
women do you consider as you as your
wife your protector definitely yeah I
and I think that's one of the things
that I connected with as well is that I
remember when we were getting married
and I was super nervous and we were
getting married back in Massachusetts
and it's 105 degrees out and the church
didn't have air-conditioning sweating
buckets and I was standing on the altar
and I turned and I saw her coming down
and I'll never forget it I instantly
stopped sweating and I was like that
that person has my back like that I I
was just and I guess I never really made
this connection before with wanting to
do this movie too because when I saw her
coming down you know the aisle to get
married I thought I'm so much more
powerful now that she is a part of my
world and I think that's exactly how
mark feels with the women in his life he
it makes him a more formidable human
being because he's surrounded by these
strong powerful women
that's kind of violent but at least the
Nazis are dead it seems so perfect that
you would do the movie with a woman who
you've known for so long with less than
man yeah I did that feel like a perfect
fit for you she's so great she's such a
great comedic actress but I think a
really exceptional dramatic one as well
well I mean we fell in love with you
guys together and 40 old virgin tonight
a different scene she's throwing up in a
car right and on me and on you yes I'm
sorry did you have a daiquiri tonight
yeah do you remember doing that scene
with her is there anything that sticks
out in your mind from that scene this
sticks out well hurt her throwing up
like a pink yogurt on me I mean that's
you know yeah that's that's literally
what's exactly the new bachelor is a
virgin The Bachelor on the show The
Bachelor is an actual virgin and so they
spoofed your 40 year old virgin poster
with him in the shirt
perfect perfect isn't it yeah I I didn't
see it but yeah that seems to make sense
so you're not a big bachelor watcher I
have not watched I am NOT a No
[Music]